bonsoir tristan a qu'à vélo merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france les
médias américains drogués les dirigeants
européens d'ailleurs qui annoncent la
victoire avant le le recomptage on se
souvient qu'en 2000 ont fait un petit
retour en arrière
george bush et al gore s'étaient
affrontées pour une même histoire de
recomptage en floride on avait attendu
trente six jours pour savoir que george
bush est élu président c'est pas le même
traitement avec donald trump est ce
qu'on peut comprendre qu'il vit cela
comme une injustice ou non
tout à fait je crois que comme le
reporter venait de le dire il faut quand
même rappeler aux téléspectateurs que
aujourd'hui aux états unis
il n'y a pas de président élu c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a absolument aucun
document officiel qui a été donné par
l'administration trump pour rendre
officielle l'élection de joe biden joe
biden doit être décrétée président élu
par emily murphy qui est en charge des
jo wood services agency et cette
personne a très clairement dit que
l'élection était clairement contesté et
qu'elle ne pouvait pas donner ce
document qui rendrait donc l'élection de
joe biden officiel j'ai envie de dire
finalement peu importe parce que les
résultats de cette élection sont déjà en
demi teinte pour les deux candidats
c'est à dire qu'on peut se place du
point de vue de donald trump ou du point
de vue de joe biden c'est dans les deux
cas soit une demi-défaite soit une demi
victoire
joe biden on nous l'avait vendu comme le
candidat rassembleur qui devait
effectuer un raz de marée bleue sur
toute l'amérique
il n'en a pas été le cas du tout mais en
plus de ça on peut dire quand même que
son programme n'a pas été vraiment
imprimé par les parts des électeurs
américains et de l'autre côté il faut
quand même rappeler que donald trump a
fait une très belle campagne et que son
score final a été bien plus haut que le
score que les sondages lui donnaient
mais vous qui a tort aux états unis
justement quel regard vous portez sur
cette campagne il ya eu selon vous deux
poids deux mesures parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a vu des médias voilà avoir un
traitement quand même il ne s'en cache
pas une fois de plus ça fait plusieurs
fois que je le répète mais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont coupé le président entre
hommes lorsqu'ils voient là il parlait
de fraude parce que vous vous avez déjà
vu ça en tant qu'observateur aux états
unis alors il est très clair qu'il ya
des médias qui roule pour trouver des
médias qui roule pour baden
la grande majorité des médias en fait
sont pour la candidature de baden et
quelques médias vraiment à la marge dont
fox news aux dents kairat en fait sont
pour la condamner la candidature de
trump jamais dire ça ça heureusement
très peu d'importance finalement puisque
les trunks a eu peu d'importance dans
cette campagne que ça n'a pas pesé
oui parce qu'en fait les électeurs de 30
la base de tromper d'une base qui est
très solide et qui s'informent en fait
très peu 1 / sur les médias généraux les
médias mainstream
si nbc et msnbc et qui s'informent
principalement sur sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire que le vote trump
c'est finalement un vote anti
establishment bailon c'était vraiment
l'étendard de l'establishment américain
le vote rome c'était un vote anti byden
entier establishments et ces électeurs
là ne s'informent pas sûr sûr sûr les
médias mais monsieur vous l'avait dit en
début de cette interview il va désormais
compliqués enfin en tout cas c'est une
des conséquences de ce que vous avez dit
voilà c'est une victoire en demi teinte
peut-être 71 millions d'électeurs pour
donald trump tout de même il va ça vaut
il va falloir maintenant rassemblés pour
joe biden va-t-il parvenir selon vous
alors joe dalton c'est quelqu'un qui a
quitté quand même à la tête d'une
coalition
très disparates qui allait de la gauche
radicale à la droite conservatrice et
j'en veux dire que je pense que pour lui
ça va déjà être difficile de rassembler
son propre camp
on le voit que déjà depuis l'élection la
gauche radicale de c'est-à-dire bernie
sanders est aussi elizabeth warren et
déjà est déjà en position en position de
lutte contre la droite conservatrice
comme john key sic par exemple pour les
postes principal dans le gouvernement de
dubaï bonn donc pour joe biden vraiment
le but principal la c'est de rassembler
son camp avant de pouvoir rassembler
vraiment l'amérique à terme
à quoi doit-on s'attendre justement un
des cris de cottages total de la
politique de trump qui semble si onyx et
chez les démocrates
alors non on va pas absorber absolument
pas avoir un des micro intégré d'un
détricotage de la politique de trump
pourquoi parce que la cour suprême est
conservatrice et à majorité républicaine
et le sénat est à majorité républicaine
donc qui que ce soit qui arrive à la
maison blanche maiden ou trump
vous savez pas et donne sera un
président de cohabitation le sénat
restera restera conservateur restera
républicain et donc il faudra pour
buydens composer avec ce sénat qui est
déjà républicain merci beaucoup tristan
et vidéos maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine à l'université
john hopkins à washington merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france